[Music]
hey daddy
just following my sisters for a minute
you guys hear that
we're gonna need a bigger slingshot
we've discovered the third island we
need to put aside our differences and
work together
to save our world from being destroyed
what we really need
is a hero actually that position's been
filled oh yeah are you kidding me
i have to get a team together we're
busting you
you're still out i'm an adult mom
right this is my sister's silver she's
super smart wait who's that and why is
she all over these achievement awards i
just don't think this is gonna work
okay so unusually angry talks to herself
self-esteem left-handed probably a witch
have fun being alone i like her next
we're gonna need some muscle
well that got dark
okay guys step one travel undetected to
the island
all the gadgets you'll see here have
been designed with your current mission
in mind the first being
invisa spray how long does the
invisibility last for
forever wait what tina we're not gonna
be able to see each other tonight
[Music]
okay so what's the plan trust me i know
what i'm doing
working with what we got
we're gonna need a disguise oh my
goodness gravy
what's going on down here
[Music]
i think he's challenging us to a
breakdance battle
[Music]
oh it's on wow
don't touch the lava tube i don't know
if i'm gonna fit
in your butt
anyone smell bacon
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
what
gotta go fast
20 minutes ago an energy surge knocked
out power across the entire pacific
northwest
this needs someone who can figure out
exactly what we're dealing with
you're not suggesting who i think you're
suggesting
we have no choice
what the are you in charge here yes i am
nope
wrong i'm in charge allow me to clarify
in a sequentially ranked hierarchy based
on level of critical importance the
disparity between us is too vast to
modify
agent stone the doctor thinks you're
basic listen pal
i don't know if you realize i'm sorry
major what was your name benny nobody
cares
[Music]
sfpd
uh meow
oh come on okay pal i want answers
basically it looks like i'm gonna have
to save your planet
[Applause]
[Music]
oh is that all you got no but thank you
for
oh asking this creature is our job is to
secure it
neutralize it see what makes it tick
[Music]
look at this i took nine million steps
today
stay in there and be quiet how much
longer
i can't breathe in here do you have your
child in that bag
no i mean yes it's a child but it's not
maya
it's not your child it smells like body
spraying an old ham sandwich
life's not fair
is it my little friend while some are
born
to feast others spend their lives in the
dark
[Music]
begging for scraps
everything you see exists together in a
delicate balance
[Music]
while others search for what they can
take a true king
searches for what he can give
[Music]
run away simba and
never return
you must take your place
in the circle of life
[Music]
so
morning morning
hey get back to work
[Music]
come dear brother our destiny awaits
okay i'm coming i'm coming i see you've
brought
sustenance for our adventure no it's
garbage for the trash can
and you left the lid off oh [ __ ]
get out of here
unicorns
[Music]
we're going on a grand and glorious
quest
it's not a quest it's just a really fast
and strange erin
it's totally a quest
[Music]
shawn's back but there's a new arrival
in town
lula who's a little alien
[Music]
she's about to discover but our world
is pretty sweet
but she's far from home
and in big trouble
[Music]
to help her get back they'll need to
outsmart
the bad guys
be prepared stay focused
and stick to the plan
let the creators of chicken run take you
on an adventure
that's out of this world
get ready for a close encounter of the
third kind
armageddon a sean the sheep movie
our world has never been in more danger
human grade is what drove us underground
all those years ago
to escape from your rapacious
appetite
[Music]
you are not prepared for the truth
behind what you seek
no you will believe
ultimas fell
[Music]
[Music]
meet rex ever since he was a puppy he's
been the queen's top dog
he's always been popular in the palace
and he's shaken paws with the best the
brightest
and the craziest fantastic little place
you got here liz oh
life was pretty good until he got locked
out of the palace
and put in the doghouse
who's a nice little puppy
rule one don't get involved with strays
you're drooling perhaps we could get
formally acquainted
oh real never cross tyson
nosy news out he ain't no dog
he's a pussycat
[Music]
[Music]
i can't get out of here on my own
united we stand divided we fall
we need to work together
our real battle is with fear i'm too
fluffy to die
we conquer it
we set ourselves free
[Applause]
[Music]
hold it tight
[Music]
what is going on in this crazy place in
this world nothing
is what it seems a few moments ago
things were different
a lot different i was with my brother
charlie it's magic
charlie don't
what's happening
with my connections i could find your
brother no problemo
one of them is the world's greatest
secret agent this way
over the last several months a number of
citizens vanished into thin air do you
think it's the same people who took my
brother i'm 100
almost sure well
well you're the strongest fiercest
warrior you can find
oh no you're gonna all fight for your
life in my arena
marla i
[Applause]
[Music]
he comes here he comes
charlie's out there all alone come on
let's mode
we're heading into dangerous territory
[Music]
there's no chance of death or anything
right
i love it i love it i love it
it's okay to be excited to see me you're
only human
all right charlie we can do this yes
tell the boss dell's here to see her i
got a dell down here asking to see miss
g
no not adele that'll be awesome
you know how you can tell when you're
the world's greatest spy lon
starting lance sterling
lance sterling everyone knows the name
[Music]
don't take the law so hard i mean you
got to meet lance sterling
[Music]
thank you thank you play it back to work
quarterbackers 2 is too much
this is probably the right amount but
still go back to work
[Music]
i've been working on this thing at home
it is gonna change spying
forever it's called biodynamic
concealment
imagine if i can make you wait for it
drumroll please
disappear disappear
disappear why are you saying it like
that
for a fact
that next generation concealment pack
you wouldn't happen to have it on hand
would you
i do happen to have it in hand show it
to me sure
um well can i offer you a drink i got
water drinkable meal replacement
we had a drink diet stuff has a weird
aftertaste
what's the tech um well you just drank
it worked
subject appears disoriented walter what
did you do
hey lance look at me look at you i can't
not look at you walter i can see my butt
and your face at the same time
pigeons are everywhere and nobody
notices them ah girl it's the most
perfect form a spy could take you better
unburden me right now that's it i'm not
playing with you
unburdened i'm raising my voice i
probably shouldn't be raising my voice
at you
i need you to unburden me walter
technically
you birded yourself oh i murdered this
boy
i'm just not that good with people
there is one thing i'm good at
[Music]
the mission was to find out what they
knew but that's kind of difficult now
that you killed everyone
i just don't think you're cut out for
the intelligence this is your last shot
how's school going oh my god you have
jelly all over your face
i'm definitely posting that on insta is
it too late to homeschool me
are you cia how'd you get it oh because
she has a camera she might be streaming
if kim finds out we got made by a
nine-year-old my career is over what's
the option
kill her make it look like an accident
yeah maybe the stairs
what wow still recording
we can cut a deal i want you to teach me
how to be a spy but just to be clear
this is a one-time arrangement
never again i can't promise so what's
first shooting range obstacle course or
to walk away from an explosion
lie detector test i can smell a lie
endorphins release an odor in the
ultimate tell
slightest blink of an eye anything like
this jj i admire all of your tattoos
stop jj i believe you that you've never
taken steroids
damn she's good when you look out there
what do you see
90 civilians minimal security soft
perimeter smiling people having fun
you should try it sometimes
the objective of this exercise is to get
past me a good idea might be to cause a
distraction because otherwise there'd be
zero chance that you get
blueberry i'm just left exterior
you're a nice guy
what is he doing this looks like the
wedding at the end of shrek
i just want to break the rules
why am i alive you are a toy
you belong to bonnie these are your
friends
woody i have a question um well actually
not just one i have all the questions
who wants to go on a road trip vacation
you need help with that no no i got it
i know this is a little strange but we
all have to make sure nothing happens to
forkey
uh something that happened to him buzz
we gotta get porky roger that
the panic is attacking me
change of plans jesse ham fuzz boat rex
potato head
hey watch it buddy let's go save a spork
do i need to be worried well my guys are
veterans i'll hang in there
i know the perfect toy to help
duke kaboom canada's greatest stunt man
oh yeah he's posing yeah duke
hold on one more oh yeah
hold on
what do you will save me i've known that
guy my whole life two days
[Music]
is that how we look on the inside
there's so much fluff we have to find
him mom
bonnie needs forkey oh sheriff woody
always coming to the rescue
that's gonna be quite a jump for you and
dude for me
[Music]
let's kaboom
[Music]
how do we get that key what about the
old plush rush there you
[Music]
where go you two come from
well we're not doing that
[Music]
you